Я не знаю Про кого говорив Зеленський но
я би йому порадила подивитися в дзеркало
і подивитися на свою монобільшість у
Верховній Раді Я перепрошую більше ніж
опзж І навколо опзжшна шушера ніхто не
розпалював і не розпалює ворожнечу але
чомусь слуги народу в екстазі злилися з
опзж в парламенті протискаючи різні
напівлегальні напівдержавні оборудки які
тільки шкодять українському народу Я би
порадила так само подивитися в дзеркало
щодо переслідування військових і
волонтерів і ветеранів тому що з 19-го
року нічого не змінилося А справа
червінського тільки підтверджує те що
влада переслідує тих хто сміє говорити
правдою хто сміє захищати Українську
державу Я перепрошую владі треба було би
подивитися в дзеркало тому що так
виглядає що Вони намагаються домовитися
з московською церквою гебістською
замість того щоб зробити все щоб її
заборонити їм треба було би подивитися в
дзеркало тому що саме радники офісу
президента є скажемо так ригівським
кодлом які називають революцію гідності
масовими заворушеннями з використанням
сили які виступали проти майданівців
виправдовували беркутів захищали всяких
портнових і тепер вони лишаються при
владі Я перепрошую А давайте ще
питаннячка що з бакановим що з бакановим
він призвів зокрема до цієї ситуації яку
ми мали з непідготовкою до війни один з
команди Зеленського і він собі гуляє А
що у нас з тими всіма е з зрадниками і
медіаповіями вони собі гуляють
тихесенько і їх ніхто не рухає що у нас
з тими людьми які роками сіяли
Московську пропаганду Вони теж собі
розгулюють тобто Влада маючи чотири роки
моновладу і я маю надію півтора крайніх
років маючи хоча би якесь уявлення якою
має бути українська держава мала би ці
речі вирішувати а опозиція би однозначно
це все підтримувала але ні вони
починають переслідувати знову ж таки
опозиційні канали вони знову ж таки
хотять бочку на опозиційних політиків
які реально зараз працюють на допомогу
збройним силам України і Вони
намагаються знищити тих військових
завдяки кому українська держава в момент
найважчий втрималася прошу пане
Зеленський і ваша монобільшість дивіться
в дзеркало